bonjour vous êtes devant le tribunal
londonien de westminster où doivent se
dérouler les audiences beaucoup de
personnes ont fait le déplacement pour
apporter leur soutien à julian assange
oui exactement beaucoup de personnes
sont rassemblées ici devant le tribunal
et pas seulement dans le pays entier
dans le monde entier sont organisées à
des rassemblements pour dire pas
d'extradition de julian assange ce
journaliste de quoi aider 48 ans est
fondateur de wikileaks vous pouvez le
voir juste derrière moi je suis devant
le tribunal de londres et beaucoup
beaucoup de monde sont juste devant
beaucoup de gilet jaune également sont
venus soutenir le fondateur qui risque
jusqu'à 175 ans de prison vous l'avait
dit pour avoir a fait des révélations
jugées confidentielles sur l'armée
américaine
et là sur l'américaine en afghanistan et
en irak pour l'instant on n'a pas encore
vu et les avocats les avocats de junas
ange par contre on a pu voir le père de
junas songe qui est passé furtivement
qui s'est arrêté pour saluer la foule et
qui s'est dit extrêmement extrêmement
surpris et agglo est très heureux de
voir que plusieurs personnes ont fait le
déplacement ici vous pouvez également
voir ici juste à ma droite beaucoup de
journalistes également couvre l
événement et sont postés juste devant ce
tribunal
ici pour savoir ce qu'il va se passer
savoir si la justice britannique va dire
oui à cette extradition et si elle dit
oui et bien le journaliste lanceur
dallaire qui a reçu plusieurs prix de
journalisme va être extradé vers les
états unis
monaco dès lors en direct de londres
merci pour toutes ces précisions